the way to success is through the
continuous pursuit of knowledge
upskilling and gaining more knowledge
from Simply learn really helped me
advance my career hi I'm Anthony palumba
I'm an assistant professor of business
administration at the University of
Virginia's Darden School of Business
all of my life I've been interested in
media entertainment and the intersection
of these two disciplines against
business this is what led me on my path
to earning my Master's Degree at
Syracuse University and my PhD at the
University of Florida when I was
graduating in 2015 though I recognized
that there was a shift that was about to
unspool regarding artificial
intelligence and machine learning and I
began to realize that I needed to
eventually upskill to stay competitive
in the marketplace I'm quite interested
in optimizing models that could help
predict audience behaviors and
engagement and consumption habits across
TV film video games advertising and
social media this is what led me to
pursuing the professional certification
program and artificial intelligence and
machine learning by simply learn in
collaboration with Purdue University
simply learns course turned out to be
one of the best decisions of my life
the course itself is very intricate and
involved and the materials that are
offered are very very complex and they
really do allow you to practice the
skill sets that you learn in class
during the program I've been able to
accrue several really great
opportunities for one I've been able to
join a renowned consulting firm a gbk
collective and part of the reason why
they were interested in speaking to me
was the machine learning and artificial
intelligence expertise that I've been
working on during the program itself
additionally
this program has aided me in securing a
permanent position at Garden School of
Business at University of Virginia so
this aided me in earning a 35 increase
in my salary in addition the course's
affordability is another great perk
school is expensive and so offering such
a comprehensive course at such an
affordable fee you can certainly Count
Me In my advice to every professional
out there would be to do the same thing
they find ways for you to challenge
yourself find programs that that will
challenge you though
I I challenge you to find a program
that's comprehensive as simply work